alexis corbière bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité politique ce matin
les corbières député de la france un de
la fraude député la france insoumise de
510 blessées
jean luc mélenchon et on est enceinte
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale vont jouer avec richard
bonjour
merci beaucoup eric on va commencer on
va parler évidemment des mobilisations
pour le pouvoir d'achat mais d'abord on
a appris ce matin les chiffres de la
croissance 7 % en 2021 c'est un record
depuis 52 ans et pour bruno le maire
leur bond spectaculaire de la croissance
et face la crise économique est ce que
vous seriez la politique du gouvernement
sur ce sujet non mais surtout méfions de
ces chiffres la question et la
croissance et la fortune les richesses
que cela produit de quelle manière elles
sont partagées de quel type de
croissance parlons nous par exemple
monsieur le maire se félicite qu il
avancé le chiffre de plus d'un million
d'entreprises qui ont été créés et quand
on regarde en détail ce sont sont des
micro-entreprises qui amène à ce qu' il
se sert tienne l'emploi avec une grande
précarité etc etc donc je me méfie de ce
genre de chiffres je me félicite si
c'était le cas je me féliciterais on va
dire que le pays aille mieux mais
j'observe que on reste encore dans un
pays et c'est un des bilans sains de ce
quinquennat ou plus d'un million
supplémentaire de nos concitoyens sont
passés sous le seuil de pauvreté on a
aujourd'hui 9 millions de gens sous le
seuil de pauvreté 12 millions de gens
qui font appel à l'aide alimentaire que
beaucoup des contrats de travail qui
sont signés actuellement sont souvent
des contrats extrêmement courts etc etc
etc al'inverse il ya ce chiffre
spectaculaire que l'association oxfam
nous a donné il ya quelques jours les
cinq personnes les plus riches du pays
ont une fortune équivalente à 40 % de la
population c'est à dire à peu près 27
millions de personnes cinq personnes
possèdent autant que 40% la population
donc voyez sur les chiffres de la
croissance oui mais là vous dites c'est
encourageant on sort de ça on ne sent
même pas d'une crise sanitaire on est
encore dans une crise sanitaire avoir
une croissance de 7% en 2021 est ce que
vous dites est une bonne chose mais la
question c'est quelle année
l'application concrète pour l'ensemble
de la nation
c'est pour ça qu'à ce stade je veux
commenter ceux ci servent lui compris
vous avez le russe avait le regard que
nous avons produire oui mais pour dire
quoi évidemment sommes-nous aujourd'hui
dans une logique de de restitution nom
adam notre appareil de production je
pense qu'on tente un pari industriel et
il tournait vers des choses qui sont
écologiquement pertinente dans la
période etc etc donc je me méfie de ces
chiffres un peu qui sont la
communication et dont nos concitoyens
après
plus que distille en termes d'emploi en
termes de réarmement industriels en
termes de partage des richesses on va
parler de la mobilisation il ya enfin
l'heure du pool alors il ya eu donc qui
hier une mobilisation
150000 personnes à peu près selon
la cgt un peu moins évidemment selon le
ministère de l'intérieur
le pouvoir d'achat c'est une priorité
des français on le sait vous aux
affaires demain qu'elle est je dirais la
priorité est ce que c'est d'abord le
priorité aux salaires aux contrôles des
prix qu'est ce que vous faites en
premier en quelque sorte les deux mon
général si vous me permettez s'arrêter
en vous remerciant de pointer le sujet
c'est à dire que ce don ce que
j'approuve hier c'est que cette
manifestation à quelques à 70 jours et
quelques du premier tour l'élection
présidentielle me semble mais le doigt
sur le sujet dont je souhaiterais que
nous débattions qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une élection présidentielle c'est un
grand débat qui va s'ouvrir entre chacun
de nos concitoyens et quel est le sujet
de la conversation si je puis dire qu'il
emporte et moi je souhaite que soit la
question sociale pourquoi parce qu
effectuons aujourd'hui nous avons un
problème de rémunération trop faible
nous sommes favorables pour répondre à
votre question et ça ça serait par
décret à ce que le smic soit amené à
1400 euros
netasq eux aussi vous avez sans doute
entendu jean leclant le dire
actuellement nous souhaitons qu'il y ait
un bhl cage des prix sur les produits de
première nécessité car nous observons
que beaucoup de produire non seulement
l'énergie on va peut-être en parler à
110 % d'augmentation 57 % d'augmentation
progresser électricité 40% sur les pâtes
etc etc bon donc un blocage des prix là
aussi
le temps que ce serait nécessaire
d'éviter ce choc aujourd'hui qui amène à
ce qu'une fois de plus le nombre de gens
qui tombent dans une précarité
énergétique augmente alors ça peut
apparaître comme une mesure de crise
mais précis et non le président de la
république nous avait dit que nous
étions en guerre en guerre
on a aujourd'hui une situation
effectivement face auquel les pouvoirs
publics c'est ainsi qu'une mesure a pris
qui nécessiterait que nous regardions
comment on évite effectivement que cette
augmentation se perpétue mais on peut
pas laisser faire les
pluies mêlées fribourg brand aussi en
verra de quelle manière aussi les choses
se passent sur nombre de deux choses qui
peuvent être si nous étions
responsabilité des modifications
notamment sur je pensais à l'agriculture
cet exemple là parce qu'il m'a été
désordre dans d'autres émissions là en
disant mais nos agriculteurs est ce que
tout le monde sait que quand on achète
un euro un fruit d'une valeur de noront
il y en a 8 centimes qui revient à celui
qui le produit donc il ya aussi des
choses qu'il faut revoir là dedans dans
la chaîne de distribution pour que ceux
qui produisent véritablement bénéficient
plus de l'achat et qui pourrait amener à
ce qu'on n'est pas des effets souvent
d'augmentation de prix qui ne correspond
pas vraiment vous presque dire qu'ils ne
se répercute pas sur ce qu'ils ont
l'impression en l'occurrence oui je
pense qu'il ya aussi une discussion à
voir avec la grande distribution et que
les marges qui ne sont pas toujours
justifiés soi vu à la baisse est
effectivement aussi
non alors en l'occurrence là le problème
c'est connaissions un produit qui par
ailleurs d'ores et déjà est réglementée
faut aussi éviter les effets d'aubaine
de grands groupes qui en profite aussi
pour détruire toute une profession un
mois je veux dire moi je suis très
attaché à ce qu'il ya encore la
boulangerie qui soit le alors je sais
bien que michel edouard leclerc embauche
aussi des boulangers haut niveau et on a
le droit d'acheter sa baguette de pain
et cela m'arrive parfois je m'excuse
auprès de mon boulanger de lâcheté
parfois au supermarché mais vous et moi
sans doute tout en ayant parfois en
faisant vos courses dans un supermarché
on souhaite à ce que cette profession
indispensable ne disparaissent pas ça
nécessite connaît en regard est
actuellement les prix de la baguette
sont aussi encadré pas donc et bien
alors en vous disant ça continue on mais
vous comprendrez que notamment toutes
ses marges ou y compris les marches qui
sont faites par les grands groupes
énergétiques quand vous avez total angie
edf qui font des profits chaque année de
près de 7 milliards 69 milliards en dix
ans et c'est donc il ya des marges
aujourd'hui qui sont faites et qui
devrait être réduite afin que l'on
puisse éviter cette inflation qui
profite cette augmentation des prix qui
profite à certains groupes l'ordre ont
alors parmi les les secteurs d'activité
mobiliser toujours bien sûr il ya
évidemment celui de la santé n'y a pas
juste celui des médecins des infirmiers
des aides soignants hospitalier il ya
aussi ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui les
métiers de l'humain ils sont mobilisés
sont les éducateurs les moniteurs
d'activités tout ce qui accompagne savez
là la petite enfance les personnes en
situation de handicap et c est ce qu
alors on était un peu les grands oubliés
du ségur de la santé est ce que vous
aussi demain je dirais aux affaires est
ce que vous les inclus et ce que vous
faites aussi en urgence quelque chose
pour eux nous on pense que il ya huit
cent mille personnes notamment qui sont
parfois la fonction publique qui sont en
situation de précarité qu'il s'agirait
de titulariser ces métiers là en font
partie les métiers du lien sont des
métiers indispensables je salue au
passage le travail qui a été fait par
mon ami collègue françois ruffin dans
son dans son film de boules et femmes
qui rend hommage à tous et souvent des
métiers féminins qui rend hommage à tous
ces métiers ces métiers du lien c'est
avait sachons des acronymes un peu
incompréhensible dans l'éducation
nationale des gens qui accompagnent nos
enfants qui souffrent de différentes
difficultés et qui en raison de ce
statut de 24 heures 25 heures par
semaine sont payés 600 700 euros 760
euros bon et tout ça n'est pas possible
alors que ce sont des métiers du fait du
vieillissement de la population qui voit
depuis un peu longtemps sans doute qu'on
va venir sur la discussion sur les ehpad
ont qui montre pialat des gisements
d'emplois nécessaires par ailleurs un
potentiel a aussi très important mais
une autre jeunesse sur la forme et pour
exécuter ses métiers mais une précarité
paradoxalement dans ces métiers qui est
absolument intolérable et c'est pas
possible que ceux qui s'occupent de nos
anciens ceux qui s'occupent de nos
enfants
en grande difficulté soient placés dans
des situations même extrêmement fragile
moi j'ai aussi beaucoup mobilisé pour
les aes h et quand on les rencontre
souvent ce
sont souvent les femmes plus des femmes
c'est souvent des vies de mères séparées
il mères isolées avec enfants parfois
même elle même ça m'a frappé j'ai pas de
statistiques mais ça m'a frappé dans la
discussion de beaucoup d'entre elles
elles mêmes ont des enfants qui ont qui
ont des handicaps etc et qui se
retrouvent dans des situations je répète
des 760 850 euros par mois 25 eur avec
en plus un ministre qui a mis en place
un système qu'on appelle des pianos
d'optimisation un peu de ses métiers l
on fera trois quatre enfants à suivre et
c'est extrêmement difficile là il ya
quelque chose là encore congé de la
grande conversation que je souhaiterais
avoir dans l'élection présidentielle
c'est l'emploi le social et notamment
mettre un terme à la précarité dans ces
métiers qui sont indispensables mais je
n'avais pas du mal à vous faire entendre
sur ces sujets pendant cette campagne je
sais pas je trouve qu'il ya des sujets
qui commence à venir c'est pour ça que
c'était utile hier de manifester on a un
scandale qui peut avoir un aspect
positif c'est qu'on discute enfin du
fait que nos anciens ne peuvent pas être
un élément de spéculations et de profits
pour certains grands groupes et il faut
voilà c'est l'enjeu d'une campagne de
faire campagne c'est est ce qu'on peut
changer de regard sur les ehpad
justement d'ajustement et gilles
bourguignon a dit qu'elle recevrait
mardi le directeur général d'orpea c'est
ce groupe qui est accusé l'été tant le
livre de victor casas mais accusé
d'avoir organisé un système de
maltraitance envers nos aînés alors le
groupe dément brigitte bourguignon le
reçoit qu'est ce que vous attendez de
l'état sur ce sujet qu'est ce qu'elle
doit faire la ministre pas toute la
lumière soit faite là-dessus je rappelle
qu'il y avait dès 2018 à l'assemblée
nationale un rapport de ma collègue et
amie caroline fiat qui avait pointé le
problème dans les ehpad du fait qu'il
manque deux cent dix mille il ya emplois
qui pourraient être créés pour que l'on
soit sur des normes qui sont les
standards qui amène à ce que pour six
cent mille personnes qui sont à nepad il
600000 personnel aujourd'hui on est à
400 milles
un petit peu plus donc là il ya des
emplois qui est d'avoir lieu et puis ce
qu'on a découvert à cette occasion c'est
que alors je le chiffre que 80 % c'est
d'établissements publics 20% ces
établissements privés et sur certains
détails sont privés le nez c'est le cas
du groupe notamment que vous évoquez ils
sont même cotées en bourse ils reversent
des dividendes à leurs actionnaires et
alors j'ai envie de dire à ceux qui nous
écoutent au delà du débat public privé
moi je suis plutôt favorable à ce que
soient effectivement qu'on développe des
établissements publics avec les
départements les mairies mais quand même
c'est des établissements privés il ya
des gens qui font où il ya des
structures privées qui sont pas là pour
faire du profit à et qui font du bon
boulot mais on découvre là qu'on a des
secteurs qui ont une logique de
rentabilité sur nos anciens et ça c'est
insupportable
est ce qu'on découvre pas aussi qu'il ya
peut-être un manque de contrôle en tout
cas une défaillance
puisque je rappelle que 40% d'ailleurs
de ski 2d budget au niveau des ehpad
sont des budgets publics départements ou
communes comment se fait-il connaît
aussi peu de contrôles et même ce que
nous révèle le livre tout ce que j'en ai
lu c'est que quand tu as des contrôles
l'établissement est prévenue une semaine
avant est en quelque sorte c'est comme
la célèbre visite potemkine à on nettoie
tout tout va bien et quand le contrôle
il est fait pour
vous ou alors il faut qu'il y ait des
moyens supplémentaires qu'ils soient
donnés aux ars pour faire des contrôles
c'est comme beaucoup de choses dans le
monde du travail une question de moyens
mais engage trawler comme il faut des
contrôleurs du travail pour vérifier que
les choses soient appliquées c'est
toujours des moyens publics quand vous
supprimez des postes de fonctionnaires
qui a moins de contrôle et que par
ailleurs même on va être relevé je vais
être sincère un cas parfois même parfois
une forme de complaisance parce que ce
qui est en creux aussi dans le livre
c'est qu'il ya certains politiques qui
ont aidé le développement de ce genre de
business pendant des années et qui ont
laissé faire et les pouvoirs publics ont
laissé faire cette situation là du fait
qu'ils avaient un or gris à trouver
grille en raison de des cheveux gris de
ceux qui sont dans ces ehpad et on a
laissé faire on trouvait ça normal de
certains de ce que nous dit le livre
aussi c'est qu'il ya un homme qui
voulait que notamment candidat de la
droite xavier bertrand qui ont été mises
de la sq il est un cinéma qui me
semble-t-il oui bon d'accord enfin
beaucoup de gens démentent en attendant
l'enquète a l'air d'être suffisamment
sérieuse pour que ça produisent en effet
comment dirais-je
significatif après on verra le groupe a
le droit de se défendre et de voir mais
il ya une réalité giraud delà de tout
quand même le livre exagéré certaines
choses moi je ne trouve pas tolérable
qui est des groupes qui fasse du profit
je dis bien du profit avec des
dividendes versés aux actionnaires sur
le dos des plus âgés
alors dans un ordre d'idée qui est
évidemment extrêmement différent on
assiste actuellement à une vague de
suicides on peut le dire dans la police
depuis le début d'année notamment alors
ce gouvernement dit avoir fait vos coûts
en matière de dotation matérielle
notamment se souvient que c'était une
une revendication des policiers
simplement
aujourd'hui le malaise est fort il est
sans doute d'un autre ordre comment vous
l'identifier comment vous voyez les
choses et là encore qu'est ce que vous
feriez vous avez devant vous un député
qui en 2018 a demandé un rapport d
enquête parlementaire sur le suicide
dans la police parce que j'avais été
alerté notre gendarmerie la police des
taux extrêmement important qui monte
jusqu'à 56 fonctionnaires certaines
années que son suicide et leur donner à
10 depuis le vieux sam de l'année
je crois que le policier qui s'est jetée
c'est effectivement de l'afuzi de toute
manière c'est un quand même assez
effrayant alors beaucoup de raisons
c'est multimodal les raisons d'un
suicide peut arriver qu'un homme
pour des tas de raisons extérieures à
son métier se suicide mais n'empêche
qu'on voit bien qu'il ya quelque chose
qui peut être structurelle qui mérite au
moins que les politiques et les
parlementaires que nous sommes et des
éléments de réponse que nous n'avons pas
très claires il arrive parfois aussi des
organisations de policiers l'ont dit qui
peut avoir un management brutal je
répète une expression qui a étonné par
les relations syndicales la politique du
chiffre et c bref sur ce sujet
extrêmement sensible qu'est la police
que les choses soient claires la police
est un service public dont nous avons
besoin mais nous devons pouvoir débattre
et critiquer et vantant la manière
aujourd'hui dont fonctionne la police
les conditions de travail de la police
les consignes sont données aux policiers
l'utilisation parfois de technique nous
on est pour interdire le flash-ball dans
les manifestations les grenades de
désencerclement
32 main 32 oeil éborgné à l'occasion des
dernièrement de manifestations cinq ou
six mains qui ont été arrachés c'est
intolérable nous voulons de savoir pour
quelles raisons alors qu on était un
pays qui a l'habitude des mouvements
sociaux le français manifestent et c'est
ce qui fait toute sa richesse jamais
souvent quand gouvernements précédents
on a eu à ce pont là un nombre de
blessés parce que sans doute qu' il ya
eu des ordres qui ont été donnés une
utilisation des forces de l'ordre comme
une confrontation avec les mobilisations
sociales ce qui n'est pas sain ce n'est
pas ça même pour le métier même de
policiers le policier n'est pas pour
affronter le peuple il est là pour
assurer la survie de vous parler on peut
débattre des conditions d'organisation
peut débattre des consignes qui sont
données de l'appareil sert de
l'intérieur sauf qu'aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'on n'est pas en train de critiquer
les policiers eux-mêmes est-ce que c'est
pas ça aussi qui expliquent une partie
de leur malaise je crois pas je crois
qu'au contraire il n'y a jamais eu
autant à l'heure actuelle des missions
de représentants syndicaux parfois plus
politique que syndicaux qui viennent sur
les plateaux télé pour dire que
quiconque veut engager une discussion
sur la police et anti flics moi je suis
une fois de plus par an type anti
policiers mais j'accepte pas d'idée
quand des gens de ma circonscription
parce qu'ils ont une couleur de peau
différente de la mienne me disent qu'ils
sont trop souvent contrôlés est ce que
c'est vrai ou pas est ce qu'on peut en
discuter nous avons proposé le récépissé
notamment le fait que quand un policier
faire contre le police parfois c'est
nécessaire qu'ils puissent donner à la
personne contrôlée un papier pour
qu'éventuellement il ya une rationalité
dans la discussion quand un jeune vient
de me dire j'ai été contrôlé aujourd'hui
4 x 5 x et que l'on puisse en discuter
ils l'ont refusé en disant que ça allait
tout compliqué et c'est que c'est à moi
ce que je propose six ans donne des
moyens si ça va ça rapprochera la police
de la population il est monsieur sous
via oops et ce livreur qui est mort dans
des conditions terribles tout de même ça
choque comment se fait-il que les
fonctionnaires qui sont engagés dans
cette histoire le procès n'a pas eu lieu
mais ils sont toujours ils n'ont même
pas été suspendu donc beaucoup de gens
sont blessés par le sentiment alors je
peux comprendre que certains policiers
disent qu'ils ont l'impression peut-être
que nous avons parfois le verbe vif
après eux mais ce que nous voulons nous
poser c'est le fonctionnement de la
police des moyens donnés pour la police
et je termine sur une chose à moi je
vais dire clairement je suis député une
circonscription montreuil et bagnolet je
pense notamment au commissariat des
lilas j'ai d'excellentes relations avec
le commissaire et le commissariat est
délabré les conditions de travail de la
police de voitures qui fonctionnent pas
toujours sont intolérables et le public
est reçu dans les conditions de
précarité qui n'est pas de la
responsabilité des policiers donc nous
re d'embaucher des policiers mettent des
moyens dans la police mais aussi
d'autres techniques et pas ce rapport
brutal parfois qui est demandé par les
autorités qui font faire aux
fonctionnaires autre chose que ce qu'il
devrait faire me semble allez on va
parler de la présidentielle la primaire
populaire le vote a débuté hier vous
n'êtes pas favorable loin de là mais
pour autant est-ce que vous pourrez
fermer les yeux sur ce résultat qu'on
connaîtra dimanche à fermer les yeux ça
existe et je ne ferme les yeux à rien je
suis un garçon ouvert mais nous faisons
campagne nous c'est un système qui a été
mis en place assez haut pas que je il
semble que le site de la volonté des
organisateurs était de dire qu'il ya un
peu trop de candidatures si j'ai bien
compris avec la position qui est la
mienne y aura plus une candidature
supplémentaire qui est celle de madame
taubira qui ont une candidature en moins
mais nous on dort n'a pas demandé à nos
partisans participer à cette primaire
dont je ne sais pas très bien quelle est
la réalité c'est assez confus que
veulent les organisateurs c'est quand
même singulier l'idée de mettre des
candidats qui ne sont pas candidats si
je puis dire et puis on a bien vu ce
qu'ils participent ne s'engage même pas
vous avez cité un nom je pense par
christiane taubira à se retirer si un
vainqueur là dedans à quoi ça sert une
primaire historiquement elle
a supprimé la question lui a été posée
sur une grande radio de service public
et 6 où est-ce que vous si vous ne
gagnez pas soutiendrait bull vainqueur
elle a dit encore faut-il que le
vainqueur bon on a compris qu'en gros ça
dépend des qui était le vainqueur bon ça
complique tout et ça rend la chose
extrêmement confuse parce que ce à quoi
sert une primaire normalement depuis dix
ou quinze ans que s'est mis en place en
france c'est qu' une forme de régulation
et que celui qui gagne soit soutenue par
les perdants on a vu le durant la
primaire dit socialiste qui avait quand
même rassemblé 2,2 millions de personnes
d'accord que ce n'est pas du tout ce
qu'est eu lieu et l'essentiel des
candidats ont su depuis soit monsieur
macron soit n'ont pas appelé à voter
pour le vainqueur et et benoît ont donc
ce coup ça ne fabrique rien alors
imaginez déjà il était partisan du même
parti ils ont même pas accepter la
discipline de du vainqueur là on a des
gens qui n'accepteront aucune discipline
nous dans ce cadre là avec jean luc
mélenchon nous voulons nous adresser aux
abstentionnistes pas au 203 5000
personnes qui sont des militants tout à
fait respectable j'en suis un qui
s'intéresse à la vie politique qui sont
sociologiquement très ciblé parce que
les gens qui participent à la primaire
sont c'est la classe moyenne très
politisée qui dit la presse moi ce que
je veux seul à qui je veux parler c'est
les 20 25 millions de personnes des
milieux populaires qu'ils s'abstiennent
ouvriers employés et c'est qu'ils ne
participeront pas à cette primaire est
pour eux faut faire campagne on les
prend pas par surprise c'est pas 70
jours qui croient que celui ou celle qui
va sortir la primaire n'ayant pas de
programme n'ayant pas une stratégie très
claire qui croient que cette personne
pourra gouverner pays c'est une farce et
un mensonge celui ou celle quelles que
soient ses qualités personnelles et je
vous fais une confidence christiane
taubira est une femme tout à fait
respectable j'aime beaucoup christiane
taubira mais honnêtement à ce stade n'a
aucun programme vous connaissez son
programme il dit il et où moi j'ai un
programme s'appelle
on gouverne pas un pays et quelques
lignes elle rompt parle de choses
sérieuses sur l'europe les institutions
le social et l'écologie donc voyez bien
vous qui êtes une journaliste attentifs
vous même vous le dites quelques lignes
donc ça montre qu elle même n'y croient
pas en vérité moi ça n'est pas sérieux
voilà et les midis dimanche à gan ne
discuterait pas avec elle pour vous ça
sera un sujet non mais la forme dont
vous le présentez résume donne une
impression s'agit pas de méprise et ça
changera rien dans votre campagne en
tout cas banon enfin julie candidate
jamais ressentir à une candidate
supplémentaires qui dit vu de loin
beaucoup la même chose qu'à madame
hidalgo donc je ne comprends pas très
bien pour quelles raisons alors j'avais
cru comprendre que l'idée c'était de
rassembler les candidatures que ça fait
une nouvelle candidature moi je ne veux
pas ramener madame taubira uniquement au
fait que l a fait le mariage pour tous
point final ce que j'entends dire ce qui
est formidable et que j'ai soutenu mais
gouverner un pays faire face aux grands
enjeux aujourd'hui internationaux la
crise écologique le social je le répète
voilà que pense-t-elle des traités
européens en cours que pense-t-elle
aujourd'hui par exemple de changement
d'institutions était pour la vème
république autre chose nous voyez d'où
avec jean luc mélenchon on a au moins
une forme de constance dans le débat ce
qui amène à ce que nous avons une
confiance qui s'est créée en rapport
fort notamment avec les milieux
populaires qui sont la clé de tout et
pour terminer par dont jean luc
mélenchon puisque tout le monde
réfléchit sur la base d'études d'opinion
peut être au second tour en vérité quand
on le regarde là si on refait ce qu'on a
fait en 2010 est en fonction aujourd'hui
0 qui nous sont donnés il pourrait être
second tour pourquoi on ne sommes pas
soutenus par tous ces gens qui parfois
cultive une forme de démoralisation
ambiante on a perdu si on est divisé on
a perdu alors que ce qu'on appelle la
gauche n'a jamais été sur une
candidature unique donc il se fixe des
objectifs inatteignables y en a et il
crée de la démobilisation
réitérez pardon ce que vous avez fait en
2017 c'est vrai que les sondages vous
donnez à moins de 10% janvier 2010 voilà
vous savez tout in écoutez moi j'observe
que j'étais déjà là la campagne
mélenchon en 2012 en janvier on était à
6 ou 7 ans a terminé à presque 12 en
janvier 2017 on était à peu près à dix
on a terminé à dix neuf et demi voilà
pourquoi on pourrait pas refaire la même
chose tout le monde voit bien que les
meetings de jean luc mélenchon sont les
plus importants nous avons sorti un
programme depuis plus de six mois de 649
propositions nous sommes mobilisés nous
sommes les seuls à faire campagne
pendant de l'expression sérieusement
d'accord et les candidats que vous
évoquez aura pascale montel gaulle
yannick jadot ils font pas campagne
sérieusement bas madame hidalgo non
c'est pas sérieux enfin je veux dire moi
j'ai connu un parti socialiste qui était
mobilisée je vois où comme militants sur
le terrain très peu d'affichés meeting à
personne et elle n'a pas de programme
madame hidalgo
début de programme qui est revenu il
part donc depuis une semaine il ya eu un
programme qui sur certains points va à
l'encontre de ce qu'elle avait annoncé
je pense notamment à l'augmentation du
salaire des enseignants mais on voit
bien enfin je veux pas m'acharner sur
nam hidalgo
quant à quelque chose qui est
extrêmement fragile la preuve c'est
qu'elle souhaitait que la primaire a
lieu peu après une fois que la première
s'est mis en place ou du moins que ça
avance elle a dit qu'elle ne voulait
plus je trouve c'est une campagne
effectuera ses déstabilise
ils ont fait le point sur les
parrainages
à ce jour vous en revendiquer combien et
puis alors on vous a vu à plusieurs
reprises avec vos collègues de la france
insoumise laissé planer un petit peu de
doutes sur la possibilité qu'il y aurait
qu on n'est pas
le nombre de pannes sk pas un peu de
bluff nom alors je juge donc susceptible
sur la tête de celle çi non mais je vous
assure nous n'avons pas actuellement 500
parrainages on est à plus de 400 c'est
un problème de fond nous avons
d'ailleurs points 16 passes pour ça
qu'on en parle d'ailleurs j'observe
qu'ici même d'ailleurs au sénat le
président larcher a dit qu' il n'était
pas acceptable que des candidats
significatif quand même jean luc
mélenchon deux fois candidat a montré
que n'était en cours en significatif de
la vie politique et donc des mers
démocrate je le souhaite fond ce geste
je rappelle que quand on part n ça ne
veut pas dire mais sans qu'on appelle à
voter ou constructeurs candidats donc le
travail que nous faisons des équipes
sont sur le terrain de sillonner la
france d'aller voir des élus et il
faudrait faire une émission là dessus
observe que vous pouvez lui nous disent
qu il ne souhaite plus faire ça parce
que c'est alors casse les pieds dans
beaucoup de conseils municipaux qui sont
très pluraliste ça amène des discussions
et c'est donc qu'ils ont marre d'être
étiqueté ils ont peur d'être étiqueté on
va le dire aussi a parfois des pressions
communauté d'agglo du présent la
communauté d'agglo qui évidemment fait
un peu la police bon franchement
libérons peut-être nos élus de cet âge
créons ce que nous avons proposé que
jean luc mélenchon une autre voie des
parrainages de 150 mille citoyens en
plus des élus et pour revenir là dessus
qu'ils nous disent à ceux qui nous
écoutent et
aidez-nous quoi je dire de la même façon
je vais pas tous les citer il ya
d'autres candidats avec lequel je suis
en désaccord total mais je trouverais
choquant par exemple wade est candidat
d'extrême-droite même bofa sciences en
france il ya des gens qui votent pour
eux et on ne peut pas régler le problème
par une telle manoeuvre anti
démocratique merci alex encore merci
merci beaucoup d'avoir été invétéré
[Musique]